new tech an old Grudge and maybe a fan
service Cameo to boot there's plenty to
parse in the trailer for the third
season of the Mandalorian rogu
apparently has a brand new bassinet
while this might seem a little
inconsequential in the grand scheme of
things what's interesting is that it
seems to be that this Carriage comes
equipped with a few gadgets there's a
moment in the trailer in which the
titular Mandalorian DIN jarin and grogu
are moving through what looks like a
dark cave a beam of light pops on from
the front of grogu's crib maybe Pele
Moto has kitted out the floating pod
with some adventuring gear or perhaps
Den's been tinkering with it in his
spare time and wouldn't you think there
are some other handy hidden features
there's also a blink and you'll miss it
shot of Dr Pershing and someone else
strolling through some kind of facility
fans will remember that he's the
scientist working on the cloning project
for the remains of the Empire it was
last seen being forced by jaran and Kara
Dune to help break into Gideon's ship
considering the Empire wants to use
grogu for its experiments it might not
be a good sign that Pershing is back but
maybe we'll find out more about what he
was up to with all those dead clones
sadly the body rejected the blood
further into the trailer there are also
some Moody shots of a ruined Mandalorian
City vocatan Cree stands in a long
hallway that looks very similar to the
throne room on Mandalore seen in the
Clone Wars that said it also looks a
little bit small to be the exact same
location unless it's gotten a makeover
in the last few decades it's not
impossible that the shot just makes it
look more cramped or the throne itself
was moved elsewhere after the Empire
Purge the planet as for Boca tan it's
clear she Harbors a grudge against
injarin for a couple of reasons for one
calling out that the children of the
watch caused a rift among the
Mandalorian population then there's a
fact that Den won the darksaber from mop
Gideon something bocatan wanted to do
herself so that she could rightfully
take mandalore's Throne as Pedro Pascal
who plays denjarin hinted during an
interview with total film then is
clearly going to become a reluctant
leader which suggests he might have to
fend off an attack from bocatan the
trailer shows Dan alongside a few other
mandalorians each with their own unique
helmets and armor perhaps a reluctant
hero will add a few new members to clan
mudhorn in season three the trailer
seemingly reveals a surprising
appearance from a fan favorite Star Wars
alien Abu frick it looks like the tiny
anzel and droidsmith is back after a
scene stealing debut in the rise of
Skywalker it's worth pointing out that
Frick isn't referred to by name so it
could easily be another anselin with a
talent for fiddling with droids the
character certainly looks and sounds
like prick though and wouldn't it be
more fun for it to be him
copy frick can you help us with this
foreign
it's not clear whether Shirley Henderson
who's best known for playing Moaning
Myrtle in the Harry Potter films is
reprising her voice role as Frick but
it's certainly possible who knows we
might even get to learn more about
Frick's mysterious past Anderson told
Esquire that she's thought of a tragic
backstory for the little engineer beyond
the film Babu has lived a life out there
is a lost love he thinks about her
sometimes when he sits down in his
workshop and lets his thoughts drift
away that's what I think anyway the
Mandalorian is set well before the
events of the sequel Trilogy so it's
plausible That season 3 will reveal more
about babu's life before he crosses
paths with Rey and the Gang if it's him
at all
foreign